in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 16, on which we commemorate,
our Holy Father, Ninyin, Apostle to the Picts,
the memory of Saint Ninyin, Bishop of Withorn and Apostle of the Southern Picts.
Saint Ninyin was a British bishop who had been fully instructed in the faith and mysteries of the truth of Rome.
He preached the Word of God among the Southern Picts at the beginning of the 5th century
and established his sea at Withorn, southwest Scotland, where he built a beautiful stone whitewashed church,
dedicated to St. Martin of Tours that became known far and wide as the White House,
Candidacasa, a monastery that was later added to this church became an important center of studies for Welsh and Irish monks in the Middle Ages.
As Saint Ninyin traveled through the land, the Word of God that he preached was confirmed by the many miracles God wrought through him.
The Holy Bishop ordained priests and organized ecclesiastical life so that, thanks to his apostolic labors,
the faith took firm root among the Picts of the South, long before Saint Columbus came from Ireland to convert those of the North.
Even in his frequent and arduous travels, he constantly raised his soul to heavenly things, either by prayer,
or by reading or by chanting the Psalms.
He fell asleep in peace, circa the year 432, and his holy body was laid to rest in his church at Withorn,
which remained a famous place of pilgrimage until the 16th century.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.